this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I just have these thoughts in my head
about
I have to do in order to live the best
life I can and the first thing you've
got to do is be more proactive about
taking care of yourself i'ii take your
meds I used when I was in my 30s I was
one of those people who had to go got to
get up keep it moving all the time gonna
but I will admit I was kind of slack on
making sure that I was taking care of
myself the way I should I would make
sure that the children had everything
they needed before I would not laugh at
him okay this is because at the time I
didn't have health insurance and so
black near cost a whole lot of money
back then so I would not buy my meds
just to make sure that the children were
taken care of and I didn't rest I
believe didn't work I had this thing
about you got to go to work gotta get up
this morning my best friend called me
and she was like happy birthday Medina
and I think she says you know what I
thought about she was reading the news
letters I thought about those days when
we would go to work together and she
would come pick up my kids first to drop
them up because i could not make it to
the car in time they were really into
school but i got in that car and i went
on that job site and it just took me a
while to realize i might need to give
that up because somebody else will be
there tomorrow if I'm not
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University